good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday it is an
absolutely gorgeous day gorgeous in New
York City listen really making me want
to die so stunning so incredibly
fabulous put it in the blender and mix
it up just one of these give birth to it
Sancerre al fresco but more so like
Sancerre infrared gene in fresco for
sure wow what a long weekend I think
that I realized weirdly enough I don't
like the weekends of quarantine because
being a quarantine II during the
weekdays like their stuff to do like
maybe gotta go to the grocery story of
work to do like the days go by faster
but a little trick I've realized that
the problem with quarantine is the
mental ability to stay in bed because
sometimes you don't want to say about
though you want to go out for lunch or
whatever so I was very hungover on
Saturday from Ben's happy hours knew him
on Fridays crazy you guys it was a Power
Hour but it was really like a power
singers I only stayed in it for like an
hour and a half but I was dancing I was
so out of breath we were working so hard
and you know I am on Thursday's episode
I was saying on my Instagram story like
I was just being so negative I be I feel
like I've just been such a hater on like
everything now it's hard not it's so
hard not to but I am gonna make a bigger
attempt to just like stay above the line
of positivity because I don't like going
to that dark place I know and I was like
[ __ ] on zoom' happy hours and it was
just because I was jealous because it
dawned on me that I had it that I hadn't
been invited to one zoom happy hour
except from from my own family and that
doesn't count no and it also dawn on me
that any time I tried to like call
snitch she was always on his oome happy
hour and just like I was jealous it's a
young person's thing I was just I was
having FOMO and I was taking it out on
zoom happy hours and you guys enjoy your
happy hours they're so cute they were
fun and maybe I'll just get invited to
some or if I'm a little more positive
maybe yeah and you know it's all about
like what the vibe is in the happy hour
so Ben literally had a happy hour where
he invited 60 people and at one point
there was like 35 people in it and it
was really hard because you were
supposed to be listening to music and
doing the Power Hour playlist and then
drinking in between but really the event
needed an emcee and I'm nothing if not
you know Oh a host at a Bar Mitzvah
like emcee for sure but like your job is
yeah and the first like ten minutes of
the half of that zoom we're like a
little messy would you say yeah I would
say I think I was confusing everyone
like just by like being an animal like
dancing and people don't know what to do
and then it's like are we all supposed
to dance
so I've actually started hosting and I
was playing games you know like pausing
the music having everyone share their
favorite memory of bed I think it ended
up being really fun because you know
what I thought people would be over it
and like leave but like every time you
throw a party like in real life like
people eventually leave but literally
nobody had anywhere to go so like the
party went on till like 1:00 with like
20 people we started playing quit Blache
which is such a fun game so did Ben have
a good birthday you know what all things
considered I think he did I brought up
the idea of going for a drive and he
literally like looked at me in the face
and was like are you [ __ ] kidding me
I was like why to be so fine like we'll
go up the Hudson Valley's like and where
will we get out of the car I'm like no
we'll just drive you could get out of
the car like a long river bank or
something to go to a restaurant you know
and I'm like no you have to use your
imagination take Theo he literally hated
the idea and like I was crushed I hate
that he hated the idea I know but he
also was working all day so he really
couldn't have taken a drive and then we
planned the happy hour like literally I
was putting the happy hour like I was a
real party like I was cleaning my house
yeah I don't know why like I was just I
mean it gives you a sense of purpose I
actually had a very good quarantine
weekend I feel like I I made every
effort to you know stay just above the
line I had the good division of the
assets between sleep and lounging and
like did you have equitable division of
the I think it was pretty equitable
because I would sleep and then I would
get up and I would move to my loveSac so
I was like not in my bed all day I
finished one book I read a whole other
book and then I started another book
last night the first book that I read
this this weekend was like so dumb it
made me feel like so stupid for wasting
my time like when you could be reading
stuff of such import you know the
classics like and I was in a garbage so
then I asked my smartest friend Dana for
some recommendations and the second book
that I read was like so funny and so
good I finished it in like five hours
and I just like I absolutely loved it
was called the unfortunate importance of
beauty and it was just a really great
profound title ya know because the whole
thing is about like you know beauty is
only skin-deep ba-ba-ba but it's like at
the end of the day honestly beauty is
powerful and it's so sad but it's so
true so sad but so true so anyways I
guess like love isn't blind
I don't know is that kind of like the
antithesis to the show sorry the point I
was trying to make before was that I was
so hungover on Saturday and when you're
hungover all you genuinely want to do is
lay in bed and I didn't feel like I was
quarantined I was like literally the day
went by in a blink I was so hungover I
literally couldn't move my legs and
honestly that's the key it's just like
being home sucks when you're hungover
all you want to be is home like you
don't want to leave and so I should be
hungover every day that's what I'm
saying the mentality of being hungover
is that that is really symbiotic I think
the word with quarantine and with
Theodora for Chaman hungover I mean so
we got a love sack today two days ago
Friday came her Saturday Saturday it
came and I totally copy Jackie I got the
exact same one as her and I don't even
have space for it but like I just needed
another place to lounge during
quarantine but that wasn't my
destination new sensation and there's
really something about getting into bed
at night you know and I mean instead of
but I'm turning over for sleep ya know I
mean sometimes on the weekends like I
make my bed at 8 o'clock p.m. and then I
just like then I shower and get right
back into it but now I've been like
getting up making my bed I actually have
my sheets in the dryer today so it's one
of those days you know it to me I just
feel like during quarantine like it
weeks are just flying by I can't believe
we're in week 4 this is four of the team
and I can't believe it's already
Passover like we were like saying a
month ago like what are we gonna do for
Passover this will probably over like
we'll be able to be together
nope no not at all literally Ben went to
the grocery store at 8 a.m. this morning
because I went yesterday to get kosher
meat and they were all out of into 3
martinwilliams
and then ass lady I'm like hey lady when
does the meat come shedding Monday
morning Ben gets up at the ass crack of
dawn goes Monday morning kosher meat
comes on Wednesday so it's just been
non-stop torture like I'm so hungry and
the only thing that leaves me satisfied
it's like meat like I've been eating so
much like tacos because I never really
have meat like on the weekdays because I
don't really cook it just like order in
and I'm loving like the whole meat thing
and now that Passover starts Wednesday
we're gonna have to give up bread
tonight every night is past tonight
until Wednesday like I'm making penne
alla vodka tonight Oh totally but you
know I'm actually looking forward to
giving up bread because like I need to I
need to dial it back a little bit I need
to dial it back but honestly they still
upon the only thing that can make this
quarantine worse it's like restrictions
on my diet I know I know I'm very very
annoyed about it plus I just can't seem
to get any kosher meat like it's so
annoying I know that's why I had to
stock up on fish I got a great fish
delivery laughs so did bed
from the Pescatore fish market in Grand
Central they're still delivering and
it's like such french premium fish and I
got this whitefish salad that like I've
never been a whitefish salad girl when
there's like tuna fish I'll just eat
that but it's just so good I've been
having it on crackers and I just like
feel so fam this has been like a keulen
airy
expenditure nice it's been such a key
linaria journey do you see that I made a
flatbread I couldn't believe it
it was so delicious it was you know it
was really a pizza um I don't know the
difference no it was a flatbread it was
so good you would have loved it I'm so
happy for you it was like a two cheese
flatbread pesto tomato sauce it was so
so good and did you watch unorthodox art
or series of the way I did I have so
many thoughts and kept them but also we
have a bit of housekeeping news because
we announced on Thursday that we
actually we have two bits of
housekeeping news both great both great
I'm excited for you guys like I feel
like Thursday show was like a little bit
of a dammit now we running up you know
quarantine it's a roller coaster it is a
roller coaster some days I'm absolutely
loving the quarantine and I want it to
never end and some days I'm like ready
to jump out my window no like yesterday
I was talking with Snitch and she was
like saying how you know in her expert
opinion like it's gonna be over soon and
I got like a pang of like anxiety I was
like wait I'm not ready my house like
I'm so attached to this place now I'm
not at all like you're actually you are
brie Larson and I am Jacob Tremblay like
I will adapt in you won't you're gonna
overdose in the bathroom okay calm down
calm down no I've just I really adapted
to my home and I think and I'm I love
that for myself cuz even on the weekends
like I always stay home but I do feel
like [ __ ] but now I'm home and I'm not
feeling like [ __ ] like I'm Palace
haunting every single day right now
you're using your home in different ways
yeah it's a beautiful thing anyways two
bits of housekeeping news both good
we're out of the hive the top of the
roller coaster is one we announced on
Thursday that we were gonna be moving to
a Monday Wednesday Friday scheduled to
limit the amount that we are growing
outside because a lot of people were
saying that we should stop coming into
the studio turns out more people want us
to do the show then don't want us to do
the show so we're coming back every day
this week yeah we'll be back every day
this week honestly I didn't realize like
how many people really just relied on
the toast for like normalcy in a sense
of structure and if we can be that for
you that's totally fine we are being so
careful so like I was really never
worried but like people were yelling at
us on instruments it was making me
worried but like we know what we're
doing every day we're taking the proper
steps if it gets to a place where we are
concerned for our own
safety and health we will real value
weight but at this point like we feel
good about what we're doing and the work
that we're doing and we think that it's
important to be in your living rooms
every single day making you laugh
talking about your [ __ ] and then the
second bit of positive it's a more
parallel news you know I think we should
be written up in Women's Wear Daily w WD
they have yeah for tomorrow but was a
preview which is that the spring merch
is dropping o Wednesday right after the
show is live it's gonna be a pre-order
situation so you can place your orders
from Wednesday afternoon to Sunday
evening get what you want however much
of it whatever the size you want and
then we'll start to manufacture the
orders so you'll get your order in about
two weeks but you have the pre-order
window from Wednesday to Sunday you've
seen pretty much everything that we have
in stock Claudia is wearing a shirt that
we have today yeah we had a few items
that we weren't able to manufacture just
because a lot of the factories are
closed so when we got out what we could
basically it's only gonna be apparel
none of our accessories are able to be
manufactured at this time but pretty
much everyone is just wearing a power
right now so we have the perfect
quarantine wear for the long-sleeve
tie-dye shirt I'm wearing an extra-large
I think I wore a size medium in that
shirt and then the cropped shirt that I
wore last week the blue the big blue
sweatshirt and then the crop sweatshirt
I wore last week that says the morning
toast will post pics our Instagram of
all the stuffs so just make sure you're
following us at Instagram at the morning
to us we're almost at 200,000 and I
think that's crazy for like a show you
know like a little Instagram show yeah I
think that's really exciting I
absolutely love referring to our brand
as a little Instagram show because
someone wants referenced it like as a
little Instagram show like trying to be
[ __ ] mm-hmm it's also back when it was
a little Instagram show it was just like
a rude way of saying it because
technically like where else oh my god
guys the person who said it like I don't
even know if they know that like we
reference it all the time I don't even
know she does she knows that she said it
yeah and technically like they she's got
no clue you know that person also has a
little Instagram show so like I just
think it's like kind of ironic ya know
it's hilarious yeah our little Instagram
show so Wednesday shot morning toast
calm for all updates follow the morning
show us on Instagram at the morning
toast yeah Emel update you tomorrow and
Wednesday and you won't miss a thing so
if you are excited about that get more
excited we're really excited we work
really hard on the drop and it's not
going to be everything that we
thought it was gonna be but the
important things we are getting to you
and we can all be like tie-dyed and
cleaning together and there's just like
so many trends that like if we didn't
get it out now like who knows the tide
is gonna be cool in two months like ya
know and you guys you you deserve it
Mike
so anyways and so many people have asked
so that's that unless that's that on
that I know what else we did this
weekend which was so funny last night we
were facetiming as we both have
ourselves manicures yeah honestly my
left hand is like phenomenal I should
literally be myself can I say oh that's
beautiful
and you got your granny color but my
right hand let me see I'm just I really
don't want to show you let me see but
when you claw it like that it looks
worse give me a delicate like that
beautiful well so I have a finger my
right index finger when I was in
Atlantic City before the show my finger
was throbbing literally it was my finger
was bright red and it was like pulsing
and it got so hot and I literally just
started like playing with my nail bed
and all of a sudden not to be gross pus
started coming out and I remember this
happened to snitch a few years ago so I
called her when I was in Atlantic City
I'm like snitch why is there pus coming
on my finger she basically said she got
like some sort of infection from the
nail place and I just got him out of
here so I blamed it on that and it the
pain went away and then when I took my
nail polish off at the nail place the
next day there was like a crack in my
nail
like literally crack 50% I just chopped
my nail in half so now my nail is
recovering like it is so special looking
like it is in the [ __ ] I don't even know
how to describe it so I wasn't even
gonna put nail polish on it but I got so
sick of having ugly nails so this is
better than nothing
yeah I think it looks great especially
from far away I see far ways I've gotten
I'm like my skills are really being
honed it's not that your nails look it's
amazing what you can do if we should
just get like a quick close-up on my
nails it's amazing what you can do when
you have to do it because I had like
tried before but now that I have no
choice like that's
manicure level as they say necessity is
the mother of learning how to do your
own nails pretty much love it
okay well without further ado we would
love to do we're gonna be cast so much
different actually you know where to
start
we're gonna recap real houses in New
York we're gonna recap on Orthodox we're
gonna sign any movie and I want to tell
everyone that I started watching once
your Hill and I have so many thoughts
oh okay so you'll share them with the
class yeah and I'll share a few more
thoughts about the new book that I'm
reading called the farm it's called the
farm Chapman actually that's the long
name but people just abbreviate it to
the farm it was another Dana choice and
it's some crazy [ __ ]
it's
boiler alert a surrogacy farm Oh
I mean it's so far it's like it's just
interesting um so I guess without
further ado oh also speaking of breeding
I want to let you know that in addition
to you know just grabbing up like firing
in all cannons for the toast redheads is
moving to twice a month during
quarantine because everyone is reading
we all want to start this new book that
snitches sign because I heard it so good
but usually I don't start it until the
day before we record the episode but
like we all have more time to read so we
are going to be doing two episodes per
month this month but it still snitches
month so she's picking the next book - I
feel like I would like snitch his choice
like a light easy light easy to read yes
exactly so the next episode will drop on
April 16th which means that you should
start reading the book sooner rather
than later it's called before we were
strangers and it's available for $2.99
in the Kindle Store which is such a
great price for a Kindle book so
download the Kindle app get to reading
join the redheads it's poppin' it's
poppin' it didn't happen now I feel as
though it is time for the fast five
stories that you yes you yeah you even
you in the back and seat of the taxi
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast that's
true sake but you know in the interest
of time I'm just gonna get right to it
today's episode is brought to you by a
new sponsor Hubbell contacts are you
running out of contact lenses at the
point that you need to hunker down most
in your life and run your life from home
if you're not sure how to take care of
essentials when your time and money are
limited if avoiding crowds is tempting
to you is tempting you to reuse contacts
then don't you shouldn't have to worry
about damage through over wear avoid the
crowds keep your eyes healthy and get
contacts you can afford delivered
straight to your door with Hubbell there
contact contact lessons lenses have been
way overpriced until Hubble they offer
more affordable daily lenses by selling
directly to you you can get quality
daily lenses for a fraction of the cost
of the other guys no prescription no
worries Hubble can connect you to an
optometrist near you and are tamo trysts
agree daily lenses are healthy or for
your eyes the problems is that daily
lenses are typically more expensive
before Hubble now you can actually
afford to wear a fresh pair every day
best of all you'll avoid damaging your
eyes by needlessly reusing lenses don't
leave your home with more than you need
to set up a convenient contact lens
subscription with Hubble to get your
monthly supply sent straight to you
Margaret Olivia Olivia Adam wearing
contacts like since they were like nine
and I remember like how it's such
torture to get contacts like it's a
whole process and I
when Margo like got dailies it was like
the biggest deal was like getting like
like an Hermes bracelet like it was like
such a big deal and I feel like it's
hidden so that honestly Hubble makes a
lot of sense you can get two weeks of
daily lenses shipped straight shipped
straight to your door for just one
dollar that's 30 contacts for just one
dollar at Hubble contacts calm that's hu
BB le don't forget to select our show in
the post checkout survey that's 30
contacts for just one dollar at Hubble
contacts calm
thank you hub oh we see you sign on get
your eyes right okay
first story some more positive news you
know someone finally is listening to our
cries for premium content because kwibi
has launched today oh my gosh wait I've
been seeing in my time hop today I got
so many ads about it what a great time
for like a streaming service to launch
you know yeah this was always there
planned launching because we had
reported on it a while back but now at a
time when like we just need content at
all times and quippy is that this is so
exciting this is so exciting I'm gonna
download it I'm not gonna lie I was a
little hard on kwibi the last time we
were here talking about it cuz I'm not
gonna lie I didn't really understand it
but Jackie and I actually had the
pleasure the esteemed honor of being
invited to the kwibi offices when we
were in LA sitting down with the team
yes Jeffrey Katzenberg and they showed
us a bunch of episodes of Punk'd a bunch
of episodes of their new show we got
like a special phone that like had the
whole platform yeah we got to like
basically watch them in the content and
try out the platform and see what
they're all about and it was premium it
was so cool right now they're doing 90
days free um so there's really like sign
on smell amazing I'm gonna I mean I'm so
bored like I'm gonna download it ya know
and they have some really premium shows
so kwibi is a new streaming platform
that shares bite-sized episodes of
original content in ten minutes or less
straight to your phone they've dropped
tons of content in April 2020 and shows
to keep you entertained while you
continue to social distance some of the
shows that they have already are
Krissi's court which is what everyone's
talking about and i heard a rumor that a
couple toasters got on Chrissy's court
because the whole thing is it's like a
real legal court like whatever the
judgment is is binding within the
California laws or whatever but it's
like silly drama it's like Judge Judy
but like a little more like silly and
there were these toasters who got
scammed out of stagecoach tickets on
Craigslist
yeah and I believe that their drama made
it on Chrissy's court because like I was
a whole
thread that went viral about it yeah so
she's presiding over just like petty
drama but with a real legal let her her
judgments have like real legal merits so
it's actually [ __ ] hilarious sister
is the bailiff it's very exciting so
there's a lot of shows a lot of scripted
shows one called most dangerous game
with that guy Christoph Waltz he's just
like the scariest guy I feel like he
played a Nazi once and he will forever
in my mind just be a Nazi yeah I know
just like a happy little Nazi yeah the
story about boy shut up yes you did
I was a they're not dating anymore but
one of my friends started dating a new
guy and like we we like ran into them
somewhere and we were leaving and like
we started walking away and he was like
bad we were like fine he was like aw
revoir shush I'm out which I get it's
like a movie reference but it's a
literary Shoshanna running away from a
Nazi who's saying au revoir and it was
such a weird thing for him to do with me
and then like never stop talking about
it
au revoir just shot not so yes Christoph
Waltz also um Joe Jonas has a show cup
of joe soapy Turner's in a show a
scripted show called survive there's a
show called flipped with Will Forte and
Kaitlin Olson there's a lot of
unscripted shows to you as a show
I saw an ad Jerry O'Connell and Rebecca
Romijn oh my god I love that I believe
it's like a house show like flipping or
something oh cool
the new era xenon Tariq Jennifer Lopez
has a showed Punk'd with chance the
rapper we got to see an episode of that
and honestly it was so good he was
punking um
Megan's Italian it was so funny it was
so elaborate like I couldn't believe how
much money they put into the prank
I don't remember watching Punk'd so much
as a kid we were like a little we also
like weren't like Ashton Kutcher's fans
and I was like MTV know when we grew up
in such a girly household like no one
was turning on Punk
no totally but I like we know the
reference yeah there's a lot of premium
content I'm really excited to watch this
and it's cool cuz kwibi it's made to be
watched vertically or horizontally
whatever you prefer if you're twisting
your phone film both ways so like you
can watch whichever way you prefer you
don't have to like keep turning your
phone I've just been dying for some new
content and I can't believe not one
streaming service has been taking
advantage of I mean it's what we had
been saying I know but it's like I get
that everyone has like a programming
schedule and I totally respect that but
this is uncertain times and people I
don't know the figures but people are
definitely
more TV than ever and I just can't
believe not one like even little fires
everywhere like not being released in
bulk or Netflix not releasing the new
season of the society like I just can't
believe there is no new season of the
society yet I know but I just can't
believe that like not one streaming
service it's like hopping up like this
is a streaming service dream no I know
and here's kwibi
to save the day save the day imma yeah I
didn't know you get a 90 days for yeah I
think I'm gonna yeah I just saw that
this morning which is just really smart
yeah I'm gonna go all-in
my stomach's making crazy noises and
whenever the microphone is picking up
are you hungry you have to do tea um
probably good you know you know duty so
a little bit of both yeah maybe just a
burp maybe weird I don't know if I've
ever said this on the show but like most
people when you wake up like what's the
bodily function that like you do like
you probably fart in the morning like no
no no been burps the second he wakes up
that's even weird and it's so weird
because to me burping is only brought on
really by like food or beverage you know
so it's like he literally wakes up and
like I think most people actually do
fart in the morning I know you don't
fart and like you don't know what normal
human bodies do but we we humans do
sometimes fart in the morning but Ben
okay you said sometimes versus like what
do you what's the first thing you do
every morning
pee no but like okay what I mean like if
you're gonna do a bodily function in the
morning like it's gonna be a fart you
know Oh Ben burps in the morning and I
only recently realized it's every single
morning late it literally gets up he's
like yeah it's so weird and like
honestly I think there's something wrong
with him maybe
yeah for sure hmm you gotta get doctor
for Chapman in there oh yeah if it's a
telescope he's writing a prescription a
prescription for loving joy that's gonna
say that we love okay well anyways I'm
excited to get on kwibi today and just
like have a new sensation I also love
watching things on my phone so I just
these days I'm like even too lazy to
determine the TV I have you been seeing
that ad for that thing that goes around
your neck and you just watch on your
neck the last flight we were on on the
way home from LA I saw a man fell asleep
with it on and he looked so dumb but on
it looked like head gear but honestly
it's genius holding my phone at my arms
hurt yeah my I mean my wrist I have it
started putting icy hot on my wrist
even though my screen time was down this
week from last week still at five hours
but we're talking 12 first hour I know
that's a lot for me I'm gonna check my
screen time from yesterday clean my
screen I was directly correlated to my
tendon in my
maybe let's see where you're at screen
time is I honestly hate that they give
you screen time well today 47 minutes
but let me say yesterday for example
yesterday was a bad day please the
perfect one I'm honest okay
Oh week okay my daily average is only
six hours honestly that's not that bad
tick tock is the most use app that's so
sad what was yesterday how do you see I
don't know Oh Sunday oh my god ten hours
okay honestly like I'm not even mad what
the [ __ ] else am I supposed to be doing
working out oh by the way which I did I
think I really lost my mind on Saturday
Jackie convinced me to download the
peloton app and she made me like a
username SEOs mom and I see house mom
was taken so she steals just mom if you
wanna follow did a 20 minute beginner
yoga like and mostly because I just
didn't want anything to high impact
because I had just taken the shower but
I don't know who the [ __ ] I thought I
was like I don't do yoga my body doesn't
move like that my hips
we're brittle as [ __ ] like killing mean
like good no rotation wake em up shake
them out no I can't like honestly I'd
rather do a dance class like honestly
learning a tick-tock know what is a
working I agree that learning a
tick-tock this and work out but I I
actually think you would hate a dance
class I think it would make you so sore
like jumping on your hardwood floor and
like no yeah also having an enormous
breasts it's like really limits the type
of workout you can do like I can't ever
do high knees you know into that my tits
like hit me him in the nose yeah I'll do
hiney sometimes but the one thing I will
not do in my lifetime and I'm certain
that I can get into shape without doing
them is burpees I mean I'm a firm
believer that you can get into shape
without working out like I'm you can
like a doctor once at its 90% which you
eat in timorous I'm working out so I'm
eating like [ __ ] and why would I do the
10% workout it's just gonna be negated
by what I eat uh yeah
I mean you can I have my own methods
yeah you know what it's working for you
thank you you seemed really really
pleased with that how things going okay
I know this is the positive episode but
we do have some sad news but I think
it's like some is about the Tigers no I
know that's a crazy story tale total no
it's about treaty teresa giudice because
her father no no oh my god Joe and Joe
Gorga's father has passed away he passed
away on the Saturday morning
really sad but like you know he's
reunited with his wife yeah so they're
they're seeing this like the Instagram
captions have really got me in my
feelings they're just really celebrating
his life I mean he was like so many
things but I think of him most as like
the guy who held the family down while
Teresa was away and while Joe was away
like he moved into the house he was like
driving the kids to school and I think
we all knew that he wasn't doing so well
because Melissa and Teresa we're both
like just tweeting out asking people to
pray for her
no no but he's been in the hospital like
you just assume he's gonna make it yeah
he died on Friday morning I'm sorry at
the age of 76 it's so sad honestly just
Teresa loves her parents so much and
like again just not what she needs no no
not at all like she just you know got
over the last heartbreak and now the
divorce and it's just a crazy crazy time
I know but it's you know I like to look
at things the glass half-full and it's
almost poetic you know yeah it's like no
no left he's stayed because Teresa
needed him and now she's free yeah I you
could yeah there's you have to be
positive and in times like this yes and
he is reunited with his wife and it
seems like they had a beautiful love
somebody he was so cute like him boiling
that live like squid in the middle of
like 8:00 a.m. all the kids are getting
ready for school he was an icon and will
forever be remembered yeah he will
forever be remembered okay next up um so
I know I said I wouldn't care about
anyone who could possibly go on Miley
Cyrus's live show yeah and by the way
before you say what I think I know
you're gonna say I just think it's
really worth noting how her numbers have
gone down because when she first started
doing and it was like still funny and
interesting and like even though like
nobody asked
we weren't over it she was averaging
when I would check in between 20 and 30
thousand people watching live I should
send the other day like because you know
now she's really just like shouting into
the void she was at 6,000 people which
is literally how many people watch my
live stream yeah so I actually saw the
truth having a guest that I was actually
interested in was Selena Gomez and by
the way when Selena came on there was
over a hundred thousand people yeah I
mean like the tea there's so much drama
there there's so much history the by the
way like the Disney games like this is
just fabulous ya know it's so fabulous I
didn't watch a live stream but I hope do
you know maybe some tea would come out
of it like yo yo yo yeah I said of
choice we got problem with that I don't
know if they dress those those times but
Selena Gomez did share that
she was diagnosed with bipolar disorder
so the Selena Gomez appeared on as a
guest on fellow Disney kid Miley Cyrus's
bright minded Instagram livestream and
revealed that she suffers from the
mental illness she disclosed that she
was diagnosed by doctors at McLean
Hospital in Belmont Massachusetts
Massachusetts which she refers to as one
of the best mental health facilities in
the United States first Selena Gomez
educating herself on the diagnosis has
brought her peace of mind so she shared
a bit about her journey with that and
that's great lovely of her to share
lovely of her to share she's so closed
off you know I think she really is so
private that I think this is fabulous
performing a lot of her young more
impressionable followers really will
respect it and I respect it as well yeah
and I respect that like these two queens
are coming together on Instagram I know
but like there will always be I mean
there will always be be like right let's
take it back like between Demi Lovato
the queens of Disney
Demi Lovato Selena and Miley like what
was the beef it was half Nick Jonas
started with Nick Jonas but I never
dated Nick Jonas first Miley Miley but
then I think also it was just like Miley
and Selena were like the two queens and
like they just they were probably always
being pitted against one another by the
network like I'm sure you know they were
like look it was a Waverly Place Yeah
right what's happening to you English
and you know so I'm sure was a lot of
like just women being put a pitted
against each other and they and a
children honestly also it's kind of hard
not to get competitive they literally
like both just had like the two biggest
shows and then they both wanted to
become pop stars and then they were
people feeding Nick Jonas they have like
the same career yeah and then they were
both best friends with Demi Lovato and
Taylor Swift and like they were just
fighting over everything so it's like of
course you're gonna hate this person I
actually feel like they would have
gotten along yeah maybe they did you
know you never really know what goes on
behind closed doors no you never really
know and now and now they're coming
together and I love to see it
I love to see it I wonder how that came
about like it's Miley diem Selena -
Selena even follow my lead I just would
love to know the logistics behind
getting her booked yeah I wonder if like
people's PR reps are like now going to
Miley being like I'd love to have my
client on your show right and like I
don't know if you saw but nene leakes
and Kim Zolciak planned and Instagram
live on Friday night like cocktails they
haven't seen each other in like three
years haven't spoken to each other and
so long and they decided to reunite on
live stream and like kind of like get
back together and they did it and Kim
Zolciak could not figure out how to get
anything
Sahn and they never did it wow that's
really sad that's where it's like I draw
the line like if you're gonna bother us
with your Instagram lives at least know
how to conference someone in um that's
actually a great segue into our next
story but I'm just gonna pause because
did you see that article that I sent
yesterday about like the The Times
article The Times article about like the
end of celebrity culture Jackie I
thought it was so fabulous and so
poignant and I couldn't even you know
there's something going on right now in
celebrity culture something that we were
touching on last week and it baby you're
like I'm being negative when I'm saying
like I just don't care what about what
the celebrities are doing but it's so
much deeper than that
yeah and this New York Times article
which I don't know the woman's name so I
apologize but it was just perfectly
pointing out like why nobody gives a
[ __ ] right now like yeah it's this weird
interim where celebrities are meant to
be like rich but also approachable and
when we think of like the rich people in
America like honestly the celebrities
aren't in that top tier of rich people
so they're like in this weird limbo
where they have to like use their
platforms as a voice to like raise
awareness for quarantine but nobody
wants to hear from them like and it's
also a terrible time to be a celebrity
according to this article and I just
thought it was really really
well-written yeah but I don't think it's
a terrible time to be a celebrity
through just like staying quiet like
sometimes all you have to do is nothing
yeah that's literally what we're all
doing in this country now but
celebrities like feel this need to like
guide us and coach us and it's like I'm
like I don't need your help
we don't need it especially when it's
like and lately it's irony and like when
I watch the celebrity video I'm like oh
my god you have a fireplace in a pool in
a back yard and like I'm so jealous but
it's also like I don't need to hear
about how you're coping when you have
all of these things that most people
don't have yeah like one of the clips
they posted in the article was like J
Lo's backyard with her kid like bringing
her a hamburger and it was just so
tone-deaf in the sense that like she
said we're managing I'm like I'm sure
you are you have a full staff yet like
you're at a resort yeah it's just it's
it's a weird time to be a celebrity in
the sense that like part of being a
celebrity is just being adored and
well-liked by everyone and right now I
think the climate is that nobody gives a
[ __ ] and we really don't want to hear
from you and that's why that imagine
video by Gaga dote and friends was just
so unnecessary like literally nobody
asked and nobody wanted it yet the
article is called celebrity culture is
burning and I just thought it was really
nice to put words to a
feeling like I can't understand how like
I scroll past people's instagrams and
I'm just so disinterested like right now
I'm so much more interested in watching
the content of my friends like how are
other normal people passing the time
like that to me is content I want to
consume yeah and if anything and I know
there was a similar article about
influencers
I mean how like the influencers are like
irrelevant but I actually don't agree
that anyone's or culture is imploding I
think there are some influencers who
people aren't really turning to right
now in terms of just even like how do i
how do I work from like how do I keep my
home because influencers really like
work from the home and they're the
experts for the most part influencers
are really not celebrities they live
regular lives like they live in regular
apartments they're like they're nice but
they're regular people their regular
young that's Millennials post-grad so I
actually disagree as well like I think
that right now like there are some
influencers like who I will really never
like again because of this and there are
some influencers who like I just
absolutely love like honestly we were
talking about this on Friday like I just
can't stop watching Heather McManus
story it's like they're so funny and
she's just at her mom's house like a
regular person like theirs now I think
more than ever like such a difference
between like a traditional celebrity and
like an Internet star and honestly right
now I'd rather be an Internet star yeah
totally anything it just because you
have like I feel like sometimes people
are like oh you know she's into work
like that house is so nice I can't
relate but it's like no I can watch
someone who's in mice houses that are
also just like there's a right way to do
something just because you're a
celebrity or a privilege like doesn't
mean that everybody automatically hates
you yeah but just like understand what
your position no literally half the
battle of being a celebrity right now is
just shutting the [ __ ] up oh my god just
shits just stop so many people are
taking their own grieves cuz they don't
stop [ __ ] posting okay like Josh GAD
cryin like we couldn't say it when the
video came out but like that was awful
right I think I did say in the video you
did say when the video came out and I
didn't watch the whole video that is
Disney money like yeah yeah they're me
so anyways just an interesting just an
interesting time to be a lot of in the
age of quarantine yeah and if any
somebody's watch the show and you're
like oh my god like what should I be
doing the answer is do nothing yeah just
be turned on and if you want to be
charitable like honestly just do it
silently yeah like that's the biggest
Mitzvah of all it's just to donate to
charity anonymous right like did you
know that Leonardo DiCaprio raised
twelve million dollars for no Kid Hungry
no because he's not out of your thirst
about Instagram yeah and I understand
that's it's it's a weird line to walk
when you're an influencer celebrity
because it's like you want to use your
platform to highlight these
organizations but at times like this and
especially when you're a celebrity or a
rich person it's like don't tell me to
donate you go donate Oh totally and I
even feel that like for so for me I just
I always prioritize just like do your
good in the quiet and like I feel like
so many times people say oh I want to
raise awareness but they just want to
raise awareness for the fact that
they're raising awareness right and
right now quarantine is nothing that it
doesn't need to be erased awareness for
like we all know there are certain
things where it's like your awareness
doesn't have we already knew that things
are bad and we know not to leave and we
know to wear gloves like at some point
it's like the awareness isn't helpful
anymore like we're aware yeah we are
aware I think I've been made aware thank
you thank you thank you very much okay
well next up Real Housewives of Atlanta
season 12 reunion will be filmed
remotely no coronavirus crisis oh my god
what yeah coronavirus has gone too far
too far I just caught up I'm gonna that
actually sucks I don't care how
high-tech it it's like literally remote
interviews are trash and reunions are so
fabulous I would beg the network to
reconsider like I'd rather get it a
month later no I know but like I'm sure
they thought about it was actually
supposed to be filmed in person at the
end of March and so they've already
postponed it and I think they just they
have to they have to get it poppin
that's all for the first time ever the
annual episodes will be filmed remotely
with Bravo bringing the hit franchises
cast back together via video feed from
their homes as all self isolate amid the
corona virus pandemic NeNe Leakes kandi
Burruss Cynthia Bailey Kenya Moore
Porsha Williamson Eva Marcille are all
expected to be in attendance as our
friends of the housewives Marlo Hampton
and Tanya Sam it's actually Tim yeah I
love Marlo so much and you actually said
something once that and I don't even
think that you like watch Atlanta as
like religiously but you actually said
how it's really unfair that Marlo
Hampton has never been a housewife
because she's like a part of every
storyline but never really is giving the
platform to defend herself
and even though she doesn't things I
really disagree it's like this season
more than ever I don't understand why
she's not house why even I really is
kind of weird how she's never been one
yeah it's weird sometimes I feel like
they just refuse to give it to someone
maybe like wants it so much but honestly
I don't get the vibe that Marlo's
thirsty to be in the group like she's
genuinely friends with a lot of people
Nene but like she's genuinely a part of
storylines like it doesn't feel forced
so I don't really understand like the
whole Marlo relationship with the
network and honestly there have been
seasons but she's literally been the
star like literally in Africa at the
bottom of the staircase screaming at
everyone like I don't I don't get that
whole thing yeah maybe she doesn't want
it but I can't imagine that no I can't
imagine that either well that's gonna be
really interesting it's gonna be awful
you know what actually I'm gonna this is
I'm being positive I'm gonna give you
the benefit of the doubt because member
when we said when they did that special
with Teresa and Joe and Joe was in Italy
and we were like it's never gonna work
if they're doing it over video we won't
be able to understand like what they're
feeling and the dynamics they did a
great job
yeah Jose was very high-tech but this is
so different like Bravo most likely sent
a crew to Joe you can't send a crew to
people's houses right now but like maybe
Bravo is sending them a camera and a
microphone in the mail and showing them
how to set it up and maybe they're even
sending like one technician to send it
up like you know a bike or something oh
and they're gonna make it good I don't
think it's gonna be like they just have
people yeah
they will do you know what actually
might make some of the conversations
more streamline like maybe they'll only
chat to housewives at a time when it
only relates to them and then you know
have people like piping that's the best
better yeah and then you get like the
iconic one like it might be very
effective in the sense like people might
really be able to work out their issues
of and he's just mediating between two
people and like the other people's
microphones are turned off but from an
entertainment standpoint like I don't
want it
yeah I I know but you know I look I look
for a thirsty housewives mall man this
also just doesn't bode well for when
this is gonna be over cuz if this is
gonna be over like by the end of the
month hopefully God willing um then
couldn't they wait till like May first
yeah I know and then it's like you get
more life out of people there's more
drama like I really feel like a
four-week delay wouldn't be the biggest
deal given the circumstances yeah it's
just that there's already been a delay
and I think you know the seasons running
like a certain point of reunion has to
air yeah so it is what it is
I think the animation what it is
necessity is the mother of invention
this could be the best thing ever
yeah but I'm just really looking forward
to like a thirsty housewives moment on
the reunion like snatching away
bullhorn oh yeah I wonder what they're
gonna wear if they're gonna get all
dressed up yeah a thirsty moment brought
to you by liquid IV everyone's talking
about liquid IVs hydration multiplier
you even heard about how much we love it
but have you heard about their latest
product in the liquid IV Energy
multiplier their multiplier tastes
amazing just like their lemon-lime
flavor you
sitting with water and drink energy
multiplier gives you a sustained energy
boost with no crash I just have to say
like would I be saved my life this
weekend because they're not when I was
so hung over I know like the only think
you're all supposed to do when you're
hungover is drink water but I find it so
difficult so when I pop in a liquid IBM
getting so much more nutrients so much
more like energy so much more everything
out of the water that it's it's not
really what it's for but it really helps
it hangover it must be something in the
world
Jaggi did you know that half of
Americans report that they fight with
daily fatigue maybe you recognize some
of the signs of lower energy increased
focus lack of motivation poor mood
unhappiness yelling about zoom happy
hours oh my god this is me
liquid IBS energy multiplier gives you
sustained energy throughout the day
fights fatigue without the crash it's
the perfect replacement for morning
coffee and an all natural alternative to
processed energy drinks their cellular
transport technology delivers an
optional ratio of nutrients for more of
an effective uptake plus their premium
matcha and green energy blend tastes
delicious and provides lasting energy
boost throughout the day get 25% off
when you go to liquid IV calm and use
the code toast at checkout that's 25%
off anything you order on liquid IV's
website just go to liquid IV calm and to
the promo code chose to save 25% off and
get better hydration and energy that's
liquid IV dot-com promo code toast
don't wait start fueling your adventures
today Wow
sign on get your hydration levels right
I love liquid IV honestly thel looks a
little fatigued today welcome some old
put some liquid IV in his bowl it's
actually not a bad idea
Oh cutie patootie I'm an angel boy hey
and I also attempted to give him a
haircut with Ben's like electric razor
what well I just wanted to trim his legs
in his belly because that's where it's
like when he walks on the street he's
like contracting the most dirt and so
the and the the razor didn't really work
and then I grabbed some scissors and
tried to cut the hair on his leg but
it's very coarse I couldn't even get the
scissors to it so I would say it was a
holy uneffective grooming session and
I'm really looking forward to Ali his
groomer you know being back [ __ ] well
our fifth and final story is a little
cat news a tiger at the Bronx Zoo has
tested positive for corona virus and I
heard as of last night it was six Tigers
yeah a lot of animals in the animal
kingdom of the Bronx Zoo have tested
positive this has really been like the
month of the tiger big time they got it
from an asymptomatic employee that's
[ __ ] crazy but there's still no proof
that an animal can give it back to a
human why it's like not a huge heel a
tiger at the Bronx Zoo in New York City
has tested positive for stars
Kove to the virus that causes cope at 19
in people according to United States
Department of Agriculture's national
veterinary services laboratories the big
cat is thought to be the first animal
known
be infected with the virus in the US I
Oh in the US I heard about one dog in
China I know very sad while other
animals all pets have tested positive
for the presence of the virus experts
say that there have been no reported
cases of animals spreading the virus to
humans the tiger was tested for the
virus after several of the zoo's lions
and tigers and bears oh my
started showing signs of written-out
bears but you know started showing signs
of respiratory illness according to the
USDA the agency expects all of the big
cats to recover well that's good but
that is so sad also just very weird
timing like all this cat the big cat hi
it's Carol Bascom with the big cat kitty
cat rescue um it's just honestly a
little creepy like this has been the
month of tigers in Koba 19 and now that
the two are one it's freaky
I feel like this always happens like I
have this theory where it's like too big
like world I mean this is just like a TV
show and a tiger at the zoo like and now
we're all talking about Tigers but it's
like these things always happen where I
was like hurricane Harvey that you know
pass through came at the same time like
all the hardwood lines steam stuff was
happening um I have a few more of these
similarities that I will share when I
remember them but it's always
interesting you know what I just find
funny about this whole story is that no
animals in the wild have caught
coronavirus so maybe locking animals up
in the zoo is just not healthy and maybe
you know maybe maybe your wake-up call
maybe Tigers aren't meant to be so close
to human being maybe Tigers aren't meant
to be in the Bronx how about that okay
no no I think um like it's so [ __ ]
stupid like what if we leave animals
alone like what about that what about
that yeah okay mm-hmm I was just
watching an episode of One Tree Hill and
they were like doing this day or night
one of the dares was like to steal an
animal from the zoo and they stole a
turtle and then the guy like ended up
loving the turtle and he was like should
we keep it and you know the guy said he
said no a cage ain't living Wow
profound Wow the animal rights activists
we need um also I have a list of my
phone about the funny coincidences oh
you keep a list yeah because I never can
remember but I don't remember Sam what
my list means except also so let me try
let me try okay I have Harvey which is
hurricane Harvey and Harvey Weinstein
stormy because at the same time that
Kylie named her daughter stormy all that
stuff with stormy Daniels was happening
okay sorry
um some and then I have another one
Jimmy I don't know who he is
I don't know any jimmies except Hoffa
anyways just a fun interesting that is
like a funny like little thing list yeah
I have I keep like a number of lists on
my phone of things I always like
reference but I can never remember it's
actually really smart yeah I'm gonna go
like I'm I need to start using my list
on my phone more even for like notes on
TV shows that we watch I know that
you've started doing oh my god because I
have amnesia and I can't remember my
thoughts yeah the only thing I wrote
down from Mahoney and Kardashian's last
week was just from the Kardashians
that they had dinner with the president
of Armenia and I was just like feeling
such just like bursting of pride for
them Jackie and literally saying all I
could think about was like what their
dad would think like should we dive into
the Kardashian yeah I think we'll dive
right in
well because start part of writing it
down is just remembering what happened
and then we can like like talk about the
moments but it's honestly such a long
episode I have so many notes from the
Kardashians so I didn't even realize
like how done the argument that they
were having was because Kourtney's like
so upset and she's so negative but like
no one's forcing her to be there and she
very well could have and should have
quit last season so like why are we
having having this argument like why did
she film the first two episodes of this
season I don't know look what's the
point maybe she thought that she could
do it and maybe she didn't want to I
don't know how the how the salaries work
um because I feel like she might still
be getting paid even though she's not on
the show but maybe she just like wasn't
ready to like really actually quit maybe
and she thought like maybe she just
needed a break because sometimes you do
just need a break big time and I really
would love to understand the financials
because Kourtney lives like at the same
level of life as like Khloe
and they don't work equal amounts so
like I would genuinely be curious how
Kourtney like supplements her lifestyle
yeah I feel like for her she is like
conscious of that paycheck you know and
so that's why she wasn't so quick to
just quit the show where the Khloe does
all those club appearances she does good
American like she has stuff going on
yeah and she's always doing like an ad
here and there yeah no she like works
actively so I would just be curious I'm
sure the money had something to do with
why she didn't quit at first yeah um
let's talk about the actual physicality
of the fight like it was wild oh my god
he was bleeding it was really really
crazy the body makeup all over the wall
was also here is he
Chloe with the baby wipes like wiping
down her walls so funny no I mean that
that [ __ ] is so real no one can say that
this show is like fake because like you
know that feeling of when you're just
like so angry like fighting with your
sibling I think dude that crack in your
voice and you just yeah cry yeah and
they both are we're having it like Kim
was obviously like so torn up but she's
so good at like not crying and crying
when she has full glam and I think Kim
was like genuinely shocked that Kourtney
like put her hands on her yeah but like
Kourtney just like got to that point I
understand like Kim was totally pressing
her buttons and it's like I'm happened
to be team Kim but like she was being
[ __ ] starters she's being provocative
but then like when you get put your
hands on someone like whatever led you
there is irrelevant because you put your
hands on someone you were wrong and it's
like even though it looks like Kim was
beating the [ __ ] out of Kourtney like
Kourtney didn't have marks on her no and
Kourtney got a face slap in first yeah
and then like him and Kim just wouldn't
let it go like they didn't get separated
but honestly like you don't get to beat
me up and me not to fight back so that's
why Kim went after again twice yes she
literally was like trying to punch her
in the face it had to be done yeah it
was really crazy it was crazy I can't
believe they like let us see that though
cuz they like value their family so much
I mean me but then maybe it just shows
like that by the time that this all airs
and stuff like they're so over it like
they're so fine yeah but so that's when
they live-tweet like they still are like
the tension I know I think it just adds
to how much people are gonna talk about
it and I think that they all are
genuinely in agreement like the show is
theirs and they want to protect
themselves but at the same time like
they want to bare all for everyone
because the I'm sure the season is doing
so well like that nobody never when they
were like cutting and pasting episodes
with Kris Humphries like we all knew and
like no one was interested in that and I
think that it really affected their
ratings so when they're raw and real I
think that it's good for business yeah
definitely like I think the fight
between Kim and Kourtney least
interesting to look at was like one of
the biggest moments they had last season
so it took when they are fighting
they're not gonna shy away from showing
that even though that seems like the
last thing they would want people to say
yeah and also like now it's like what
else I guess now but that they have
their kids and stuff they have other
things that they want to protect so it
used to be like we're not gonna fight on
camera because like family is everything
but now like they have other things that
are everything so like if we need to
fight on camera sometimes it's fine
because like we're doing that so that we
don't have to show this up I mean we
protect the kids yeah and we protect
like our husband yeah totally um so then
they all sat down and Kourtney said
something that really like rubbed me the
wrong way and it was just like
indicative that she
Willie can't take responsibility for
anything cuz whether you're agree with
her not like everyone in every fight has
things that they're wrong for she goes
my attitude is a reflection of how
they're treating me there's when she's
talking about Khadijah and Malika like
you okay so you're acting out because
they're treating you poorly like you you
can't even take responsibility for for
any of it like it's all on them mm-hmm
and that's what Kim was saying it's like
so many people are telling you like that
you're acting out like maybe it's you
like maybe not everyone's against you
like maybe people are worried about you
yeah I think it's just like this cycle
and I'm so not on Kourtney side at all
but at a certain point when like Kim and
Khloe are like so close and you're on
the outs like yeah every time you go
talk to them you're gonna have your
guard up and you know when she said like
I came there in such a good mood it's
like your mood was able to be flipped so
quickly because like you're just so
sensitive to like the the dynamics
between the three of you right now yeah
and I guess it is weird because Khloe
Kourtney like used to be they used to
leave Kim out all the time and they
weren't like mean to Kim and Kim never
really cared because Kim has always been
like this is business business but it
must be weird for the dynamics but
that's what being sisters started like
dynamics always chicane annex oh wait I
think you and I spend the most time
together out of all the sisters like it
wasn't always like that yeah that's just
like you grow up and like things move
around like its life yeah I'm also cuz
you like started crying when she was
with Kourtney and it was so dramatic
like for someone who's never on the show
she needs to relax it was so dramatic
and I really didn't like and I feel like
again this kind of like goes against
just like their family ethos where it's
like friends are coming in and like
moderating or even having anything to do
with a family fight and it's like you're
not family but I think they're like
desperate for castmate Scott is now
involved like everyone's leaving the
show Kendall was even like a part of
this week's episode more than she's been
in the last five seasons
I didn't think need people yeah bodies I
know but it's like I don't this is a
family matter yeah and I honestly I
wasn't agreeing with Malika and Khadijah
as advice to the family like I don't
like I didn't think they were good
moderators no because like Kourtney is
wrong so now let's take it to Paris I I
don't know why it was never an option
for Kris to walk in the show she's 20%
of Kylie cosmetics and honestly would
have made a lot of sense it would've
been great for a makeup brand like an
older woman yeah I don't [ __ ] I didn't
understand that I don't know but they
didn't show us a conversation of Kris
talking Olivier but she said it was fine
yeah I mean what is he gonna do she's
not coming she's not coming yeah I
didn't realize how big of a deal it was
that she didn't go until I watch these
episodes like when I was like good she's
putting her out first she can't go you
know and not ever go to Paris Fashion
Week right Lauren Conrad but
I think that's exactly why it was a big
deal because it was a big project and no
one even spoke about it
yeah like there were a few articles
about Kylie being sick but like nothing
about maman yeah but I do think the
collection like sold out so it was fine
but yeah just they didn't have that big
moment that they were going for yeah
okay now let's go to Armenia Kem corneal
literally doesn't suck complaining she's
in the museum sleeping crying about the
pan so crazy when she was like leaning
on Mason shoulder in the museum I was
like stand up straight come on no Jackie
it was horrible it was horrible yeah and
then the fans like I think that the way
they were like talking about fans
especially the confessionals like you
have to be so delicate delicate because
these are people watching a show they're
people who care about you they literally
support your entire lifestyle but like
you're obviously entitled to your
privacy and honestly I thought Cortney
was a kind of disrespectful about the
whole thing oh my god that she was and I
understand like you know you don't want
to be mauled at all times but like and
maybe sometimes you have a point I'm
sure when they come to like New York
City it's crazy but like you're going to
Armenia the people there are so proud of
you and like just want to like even see
you or have like a little piece of you
and like you're such an icon there and
to like not relish in that why are you
even going or to not really understand
like the obligation that comes with
being the most famous person from
Armenia like Kim totally gets out like
I'm sure Kim's tired but she totally
gets how what has this responsibility
that she carries and she's happy to do
it
yes so that was like the whole vibe I
got from the episode was like obviously
I love Kim but I like loved her so much
more like seeing how she feels his
responsibility to like be proud and be
Armenian and like talk about the
Armenian Genocide and she's just like so
proud of her history and so proud of
like tibi Armenian and like wants to do
everything to help Armenian culture and
I just like loved her for that no I
absolutely loved her for that it's like
we're the same way like we're so proud
to be Jewish like yeah I think if we
ever got to a stage in life we're like
we were like being invited by the
President of Israel I minister to like
go to Israel and just like have all this
influence like it would be such a proud
moment and I if any of our siblings were
like falling asleep in the museum at all
like I would I would be mortified I
would be mortified and Kim didn't even
say anything like with just the
conversation in the car afterwards and
like corny illiterate gets out and like
stops in the middle of the conversation
like I just saw her attitude was so
weird but then when they got home she
was like it was amazing chat really and
she wants to go back yeah
jet lag one more time jet like you took
a [ __ ] jet like I just hard for me to
feel bad for people it's so hard for me
to feel bad for you but also like okay
jet lag is real but like you travel all
the time and you're fine you'd like to
go to Italy and post pictures on a yacht
yeah but you're not fine to just go to a
museum for an afternoon yep I just
thought her demeanor was like so
disrespectful the whole trip and it's
like no one was making you go on that
trip so like that's the whole thing it's
stay home stay home stay and she was
like I wish I don't bring the kids well
you know special that is like your kids
come on Armenia like I just I couldn't
relate to her for someone who's like so
obsessed with being a mom and like her
not to understand like what a special
moment that could have been for her kids
like was just confusing yeah it was it
was really confusing it was yeah I don't
know how even if she wasn't feeling it
like how you don't put on like a better
friend because it's just like so
terrible and like terrible looking um
another moment I just really enjoyed was
Eva Longoria oh that was funny yeah that
was cute I love a little glimpse of and
then the episode ended with Courtney
like obviously quitting talking to Steph
Shep and her other friend who like
obviously looks like they couldn't give
a [ __ ]
but I just want to say like clean Khan
was like one of the saddest Khan's I've
ever seen yeah it's one of the more sad
Khan's and here's what's annoying is
like it's not like oh I'm quitting the
show it's like I've made the decision to
step away from the show and only show
the things that I want to show so some
of the work that I'm doing like clean
cotton it's like we're gonna be maybe
five years ago like ooh you're like an
advocate for clean beauty that would be
cool but like your sisters literally
like going to the White House getting
people out of prison it's just like a
clean Beauty conference it's just not
gonna cut it
no it's just not gonna cut it and
honestly like even if it was beauty con
like I still might be like not even
really interested but like this sad con
with her sad dressing room like it was
just all too sad for me and it was like
a perfect way to see her go because I
wasn't upset know when it's like either
leave the show and take everything with
you but don't just leave a cigar bit
clean con yeah like the filler the hell
[ __ ] had nobody wants to see nobody
totally it was a really good episode
honestly Kardashian episodes have been
so good and I've said it once - say it
again I'm loving Thursday nights loving
and now we have her honey as well so
Thursday nights are just a good night
it's good night to be a toaster
let's talk about Roni honestly I didn't
really have any notes because it was so
boring and I was really getting
frustrated but what do you think about
them acknowledging Bethenny's departure
oh I thought it was like so weird that
they just like wanted everyone to
sit there look at their phones and talk
[ __ ] they wanted to make it seem like
they caught everyone with the breaking
news yeah but like Luann's like all
glammed up in the park and she happens
to like stumble upon it yeah um I
thought it was kind of contrived and it
was like everyone was so happy to see
her go because now it's like you know
teachers at gone classes you know recess
time and everyone's gonna go crazy
because there's no accountability and
like everyone acted like no one would
ever have said those things like if they
had to see Bethany the next day worse
and it's just like they're so two-faced
mostly not even cuz they like talk [ __ ]
about her because they're so scared of
her yeah yeah when she's not dear
when she's not there they're like what's
so funny is that all the housewives
franchises are produced by different
production companies and honestly I
think the one that does real houses in
New York does a terrible job like the
tag lines are bad the theme song is like
so weird and like the new black and gold
vibe like and I think part of why roni
at first episode I wasn't alone with
it's just a production company I don't
know which one it is and what other
shows they produce but for the most part
they all are produced by different
production companies and I really was
like not enjoying this episode like it
was just so staged and so weird the
beginning of rioni season is always
weird because they're coming back from
summer where they haven't seen each
other because everyone's like in the
Hamptons doing their own thing and by
the way of all the housewife franchises
I would say the Real Housewives of New
York grip like the women are really not
friends on the off season yes so it's
always like a stumbling back together
start um but there were some things that
I thought made it very good first of all
Jordan having a party right off the bat
was great got all the women together I
usually don't get that - like Episode
three and I thought - ready to look
fabulous like I actually really liked
her hair cut in her bob on blazer
I completely agree and I love John I
just have to say like he went from being
my Merman he was like yelling at women
getting drunk and like getting kicked
out of parties to literally just being
like a sweetheart ya know I shipped the
two of them even though they are no
longer together so that's like hard to
watch knowing that it doesn't end well
um I love the new housewife love love
her I actually used to like wear her
clothes okay I was gonna ask you I never
heard of married to the mob and I would
just like some some more financial
information okay so I remember when she
was telling her story I've heard of
married to the mob when she was saying
and then she told her story about how
she used her police settlement to start
her company and I remember I had heard
that like when I was like used to shop
so when I used to shop it like Karmaloop
and like it was kind of similar to like
not while I was gathering them when it
was but like it was just like more
we're um or like Joyrich I don't know
you wouldn't really know these brands
but like it was cute stuff mm-hmm
and she's so cute she's so cute my
daughter's so good she's so pretty I
love the relationship with her
ex-husband I love how she was defending
Tinsley like she doesn't mean no but
like Tinsley brought her and kirinda was
being a [ __ ] animal a [ __ ] animal
and I like that she's obviously like if
anybody's gonna come for her this season
like it's gonna be a good fight yeah and
then the the previews like she looks
like she become friends with everyone
she gets comfortable she drinks a little
bit that police story was crazy was
crazy I actually also really liked her
like drinking journey yeah I really
could relate to it because it's like I'm
sitting the same way where it's like I
just don't drink anymore cuz I just
can't deal with all the trouble that it
causes but like when I do sometimes it's
fine but every 20th time it's like use
your passport lose your bag lose your
life the real the episode of New York
was like really making me want to go to
a party like it was just reminding me
like literally that place where during
the hunter party was where my beacon
after party was like I just want to go
to a party yeah it was it was that's
like what's hard to watch is like we
can't do any of those things also what's
hard to watch is that like Tinsley is
like the star of the show she brought in
the new girl she was like a big part of
the storyline I know the end of the
season like it really becomes all about
her cuz she moves to Chicago and I just
I'd like her as a person but as a
housewife in a star on TV I cannot be
bothered to care about anything that
goes on in her life like I find her
someone interesting I'm the opposite of
her she's just like so we Neill Ike with
great wienie like I just went she was at
the boxing place and here's think I
actually really liked her and I just I
want her to just be better but then
she's so cheesy and corny yes my hopes
he's a part of things
and when the guy was like nobody cares
yes she's like anything no nobody he
wasn't even being funny knowing serious
she doesn't get that through her head
like nobody cares about her lashes I
just I can't stand her sometimes but
then it's like with the fight with
Dorinda like I don't even like tins they
actually like to render more but Drina
was so wrong first of all let's just say
for argument's sake
Scott and Tinsley have an arrangement he
pays her bills that she sucks his dick
like let's say that was the arrangement
like why is that to wring his business
and and Dorinda like let's just say
everything Dorinda was saying was true
she still has no right to be mad Tinsley
hasn't done anything to Dorinda
Dorinda is just like taking umbrage with
things that she thinks Tinsley is doing
in her personal life which even if she
was it's not her [ __ ] business and
then she was just going so below the
belt
yeah
like if you want to come at someone with
accusations that they're denying okay
bring some [ __ ] receipts otherwise
you just look like a crazy conspiracy
theorist and she very well might be
right red this is the situation but like
oh look why does Dorinda care I don't
know like her and Cindy are not best
friends so if a girl that she knows has
a boyfriend who pays her bills why she
can still bend to the shape I have no
idea it's so weird that is really so
weird and I thought Tinsley even though
she's like such like a scared cat she
did a good job defending her she was
drunk and everyone does better when
they're drunk and I don't I don't even
like Tinsley I think she's actually one
of the worst parts of the show but she
was so right like she was just being
bullied for no reason
yeah and I like that Lia stood up for
her yeah I don't know why I like her no
I get my like her because she's so cute
honestly she shouldn't be the star of
the show like Tinsley Mortimer she's in
New York socialite rice it's a great
story comeback but mugshot like it's a
just I can't prove for her cause she's
you know she's like that's exactly what
it she was brought on the show for you
to root for her like to come back and
literally she's the definition of
nothing of the sort
yeah like her trying with the eggs last
season and crying at the circus like
none of it does it for me like these
gifs I see them on Twitter and I don't
care though the circus and the eggs are
like the worst parts but then it was
like it was in the like the quieter
moments that I liked her you know what I
mean how so I don't know like when they
were in Miami and like when I like I
forget I had I would have to rewatch
last season but like when she was like
her friendship with Bethenny was just
like really came there was just like
moments where she was just being herself
and not because like it was probably
moments that she didn't even think we're
gonna be on camera versus like the
circus moments that she knew was going
to be get like to be honest I can't
point to one moment where I thought
anything she does is did is like cute
funny smart or interesting I just like
I'm the opposite of Tinsley yeah I just
don't like her yeah but you know who I
love who's just like every season
getting better and better
so yeah like she's such a good friend
and you know it's so crazy she also
really rebranded herself like there were
a couple seasons where everyone thought
she was an alcoholic and she was so
crazy was on pills and like she wasn't
and she just stopped drinking just to
prove to everyone that she could and
she's just so fun and she's a good
friend like you need to win like LuAnn
has been such terrible things to
everyone on the show but Sony like
justice is still a good friend turn I
love Sonja yeah
when also lost not away the way looks
different well I think II taller people
like some people messaged me saying like
what work did she have done I honestly
think she just lost weight yeah and her
face changed because of it yeah and like
her arms are like so toned well she's
like on this crazy tour and I think she
actually just doesn't eat it
yeah but the probation thing like I
actually felt that sigh of relief for
her like I've never been on probation
but I imagine it's torture like just
having someone like being so involved in
your life like a stranger so I was
actually really happy for him and I'm
done talking about it
uh yeah I agree I'm excited to move on
to this next chapter also I really like
that leah has actually never seen the
show before yeah a lot of house eyes
come in and they pretend like they don't
watch yeah but like the fact that she
didn't know each other oh yeah yeah that
was funny yeah and then when they were
talking about her arrest he wasn't clear
that she had heard some stuff from
Tinsley but like really didn't know the
extent of it I agree and I liked I just
like her she's just seen some people
just have it you know yes and a lot of
people are comparing her to Dana from
Vanderpump rules that they look alike
yes and they're just two girls who just
had it you're so right
Ramona Greg in the restaurant was
absolutely hilarious but honestly you
see Mitchell Adele of course oh my god
we always talk about him on the show
because his episode episodes of
Undercover Boss are so iconic you guys
if you haven't seen the Modell's episode
of Undercover Boss you will never
understand why we always talk about
Mitchell Mondale you have to watch and
actually recently ran an entertainment
and nobody when I was sitting with
Jonathan came on who knew him and it was
just like the whole thing was too
fabulous for me like I was just living
in the moment and you just what did they
like Modell's and fabulous at the
Embassy intended I know and and he
actually was live-tweeting the episode
he's like oh I just heard Modell's was
going out of business no sad so sad but
you know if anything if they had a great
run and if we've learned anything about
Mitchell Motel from his numerous
appearances on Undercover Boss it's that
he'll make a comeback yeah um it was a
fine episode like I just went on Ramona
ends up with Mitchell motive I don't
know why she wasn't all over at me a
wealthy guy you know I think he married
it was so not it for me like that
William Ramona's friend William and I'm
so over that home he's like 20 years old
and honestly it was being funny Lee it
was being so funny and her confessional
I'm just really excited about her it
seems like she's like
Bethany with a clean slate Bethany with
a clean slate like a little um like an
interesting background I just feel like
there's more about her like I can't wait
to hear more about like her husband I
want to see her house I need to see her
Parma Chilton Chelsea yeah I'm excited
yeah it needs to be done yeah she's
kidding so he was fine it was fine it
was fine but it's something it's content
I'm so excited for Beverly Hills like oh
my god then when I say the city April
15th okay that's like a little far away
but that's obviously five days before th
Gio's birthday and it's one day before
the next episode of the redheads and
it's gonna be here before you know it
because I actually feel like quarantine
is flying by yeah it's weird the days ER
so it's like camp
the days are long but the weeks are fly
by that's what they used to say I camp
okay now let's go dive into our toasts a
series of the weekend and then we'll
give our new assignment and that segment
is brought to you very appropriately by
hush blankets and I just really feel
like I want to get on my soapbox and
yell at everyone who doesn't have a hush
blanket now that I got a love sack I've
been laying on it with my weighted
blanket it's just so premium and been
literally it was laying on yesterday's
like this plank it's heavy I'm like it's
a weighted blanket been the hush blanket
is substantially better looking and
better quality than any other brand on
the market of wind blankets they make
their products with only the best
material and here are some of the
benefits of having a weighted blanket it
can give you a deeper sleep it can cause
you to stay asleep longer it feels like
a hug and is helping to prove people who
experience anxiety or stress they also
the give back program at hush blankets
they donate one one in 10 adult blankets
and one in five kids blankets to
charities and shelters in need it's been
a huge part of their brand since day one
they understand that not everyone can
afford a harsh blanket but they
absolutely deserve to experience a
better sleep so if you buy it they also
give you a hundred night guarantee you
have a hundred nights to test out your
blanket if you don't love it send it
back to them for a full refund no
questions asked if you feel like it's
too heavy or too light you can exchange
sizes Jackie and I both have the throw
and I've won in navy blue what colors
yours navy blue as well have you like
the best feeling is like being under the
hush blanket like that's what I do
during the day now to Cummings I he's
like I'm love sack under the hush and
you're losing a sandwich I I totally
agree and like the hutch plank it is
like the Mayo oh for sure if you feel
like it's too heavy or too light you can
exchange sizes returns and exchanges are
super easy and if you want to get one
you want to get $50 off make sure to use
the code toast at hush blankets calm
that's toas tea for $50 off that's a
pretty big chunk of change
hutch blankets calm thank you for
sponsoring the show and thank you for
sending us blankets because they truly
changed my life yeah they would keep
interesting it's really the best
quarantine friend you could have okay
unorthodox and what are your thoughts we
let me actually grab my notes I'm going
to start with all the positives because
there were so many because overall I
really enjoyed it just as a
work of art the story was so good at
space-time a true story which I love I
just want to say I got um three
followers on peloton Wow yeah Thea's mom
she's gone crazy it is based on a true
story but there are multiple articles
pointing out like how different the real
story was but who cares shows do that
all the time so that's fine with me um
it was really moving like I really like
was emotionally invested in both sides
of the story I thought it was so well
done I thought the acting was
spectacular I mean I thought the fact
that they did the whole thing in the
it'sh is one of the most impressive
things and you know dishes like a
forgotten language and with all Jewish
actors and when I went to look up the
person who plays SD um I was like hoping
that she was Jewish because that would
just like add to the story but then I
saw that the whole cast is like Jewish
or is really I mean the guy who plays
uncle is so hot have you seen him oh my
god I know I mean like he's so we
kneeling on the show but no uncle I show
he's a good-looking guy and you know you
actually like champion him and he's a
he's a good guy hard a part of the thing
that like was made me trepidatious to
watch it it's like as a Jewish person
who's like constantly feeling like
everyone hates Jews like you're always
nervous to have your religion put as on
as the spectacle and what was it made
clear in the documentary that I actually
I mean that's documented the series that
I actually did research on my own and
figure it out afterwards was like this
particular community of Jews is
considered this set maar it's called the
Satmar community and they're very fringe
like they're very like they're they're
not into even like of the highest
religion of do like Jews like Orthodox
acidic like they're just totally
disassociated and there were a lot of
negative things like about the community
like especially in this way that meta
treated women that it does in real life
but like the set in our community is so
fringe and so like not a part of like
the core religion of Judaism and people
who don't know about the different sects
of Judaism who just sees like curly
people in black hats like you just loop
all Jews in together and I felt
frustrated that the documentary like now
someone who doesn't know the intricacies
of the Jewish community or Justin like
doesn't even like Jews like this just
gives people like another reason to
dislike Jews and that was frustrated
yeah I didn't even when I watched the
show I just assumed that they were
husted in which is like the highest sect
of religious Jews and
I didn't realize that they were set Marv
set Marv and like like the set Marv
community like they don't even recognize
Israel as a Jewish state like they have
a lot of differences of opinions right
with all Jews and so when I thought it
was just the Hasidim I was like well
it's kind of really strict there but and
by the way I know a lot of consider
people it's not like no and like there
are so many specific people in Orthodox
people who are so fabulous and like
they're I mean they're they all are so
to focus on the one community that
doesn't even represent like Judaism yet
now this is the show about religious
Judaism because I physically look like
Jews yeah and then yeah and they're so
religious yeah they're the Julius Jews
but they actually aren't at all and it
wasn't until you told me that that I
realize that it's really like I
understand that this is this woman's
story and then it happened then that
it's real but like when not so many
stories about religious Jewish people
get made and then that's the one that
does it makes the whole community look
like crazy wait like even me like an
educated viewer like I still didn't
fully understand like that they were
talking about the Satmar community and I
just feel like no there was only that
one comment in the whole hog on des Pig
when they when moisture is like saying
that that he's spitting on Zionists it
was like oh and then like I was a joke
yeah I didn't understand it either at
but then you told me that they're part
of that community they even like they
protest the Israel Day Parade yes they
don't agree with Jews living in the
State of Israel like so and that's not I
mean that's not how both already of Jews
feel so even though I like this story
from like an entertainment standpoint
like I said I was championing SD I just
had to pit the whole time because even
like as an educator view I just know
people are gonna watch it and be like
[ __ ] Jews like the whole thing with
terrible towards women the whole thing
with the women was just so hard on
that's just like not what Judea was
about like literally Judaism if you read
the Bible like from the perspective of a
Jew like it's all about lifting up women
like it's just it was frustrating but I
just like the show yeah and the Torah is
like an open book and it's like it's
alive so like things that happen today
like can change how we interpret the
tour and it's like most people don't
interpret it in this way that it was
meant to be interpreted in like it's
very old in 100 BC right like they live
the way the Bible was written like they
then then they don't evolve and so
obviously everyone is you know open to
practice whatever you know they want to
and so
I'm happy for them but when it's like
all the only really big examples of Jews
that we see are either unorthodox which
you're showing the set Mara husted and
which is like makes also sinem look like
that's what they practice or you know we
just have Harvey Weinstein and Jeffrey
Epstein it's like so true you don't get
anyone in the middle by the way fabulous
as normal that is so [ __ ] no it's like
made up and set Marc uh-huh
oh my god that's so true we we were not
Orthodox but we grew up in a like an
Orthodox communities like there are so
many fabulous wonderful like fabulous
Retta below Orthodox Jewish people even
in the Ashkenazi community and the
Sephardic community who have come over
from Africa and they have incredible
stories and like so true you don't hear
about any like and it's not I'm sure a
lot of religions and minorities feel
this way where it's like you know our
community is a spectacle and like we
need more stories about these stories
being told are like the extremists one
or it's like Holocaust ones and oh wait
that's one there's so much more in
between and so I thought it was a great
show but like wouldn't take a step back
it's like okay so now that's the image
of Jews that's out there I know that the
people are like looking at in 2020
there's like it's not great I'm secretly
hoping like nobody watches the show yeah
even though I did enjoy it I enjoyed it
thoroughly it made me so emotional like
when she was singing her prayer because
she that obviously doesn't know any
other song I was literally crying like
it was so beautiful and like I felt so
much for Athena I'm so proud of her for
leaving but I also felt so much for
yong-ki when he cut off his pay it's
like I was crying it was before I knew
his stuff he was such a nice boy it was
such an like he tried so hard okay and
like it also made me realize like all
Jewish boys and their mothers like I
should I know no matter what community
but I had two major problems with the
ending one like we never got a clear
thing on like what's gonna happen with
this child
hmm well now she's with her mom and oh
my god that guy that she hooked up with
was so hot that's my other man fact that
he's also Jewish like in real life
Oh loves that but here's my other
problem with that please we had to
witness that awful sex scene of her and
her husband like it was just so painful
to watch like I just wanted to cry for
her but we don't even get to see the
sexy Berlin guy like yeah [ __ ] yeah I
wanted to see her experience real
intimacy right I'm gonna get to see that
I
literally pissed no it was it was
upsetting um but they were like so cute
Minh she like first got there and she's
like in her little Shadle and going to
the beach like I I just she was
literally so cute she's an incredible
actress if she doesn't get nominated for
an award from this I have not seen
better acting in the last year agreed um
she should be nominated for every award
applicable because it was fabulous
fabulous acting yeah it was just
frustrating for me that there wasn't
more of a delineation between like
normal Jews and these people yeah that's
one yeah and it's like now people think
like if you're Jewish we're gonna come
follow you with a gun like yeah no but
someone's commenting that like people
are open-minded and understand that
there are extremists in all religions
but I don't think that show made it
clear that those are like the serious
extremists they're not even the most
like the Hasidim are the most religious
but they're not extremists no they're
they're the most real it like
ultra-orthodox lis people in Brooklyn
that's like one of the epicenters of
religious Jews like they're not that's
that they're the highest level of like
orthodoxy and even they are not even
close to the set bar right so I feel
like even though it's like an educated
Jewish person that wasn't clear to me
that these are like that fringe group of
people yeah I just assumed that they
were just like that's what goes down in
the Hasidic community same and at first
I started watching you cuz I was
frustrated like I know Hasidic people we
are related took us at people like
that's not what it's like and then after
reading that New York Times article just
like explaining the differences I was
like what is said Maher and I did a
bunch of research and it was just
frustrating that like it was on me as a
viewer to like figure that out and I'm
like an educated Jewish should be aware
like the average person who might not
even be Jewish is not gonna do that
level of research right right like I
wouldn't have an I would have said like
totally different things on the show
today if I didn't talk to you about it
last night right so overall I mean it's
great show but just like as a Jewish
person I'm like it was Pittsville yeah
and that's just always what it's like
watching anything about Jewish people
because like you said it's like the two
extremes of being portrayed and I think
that's like a universal struggle like
not just Jewish people be like any
religion that's depicted like I'm sure
people have problems with it but it was
just frustrating but it was still really
good yeah so that's that on that
um is that OB God I think that's all we
got we have to assign our next toast mo
yeah which is something that was highly
requested and the snitch recommended it
might always trust the Senate
recommendation and it is called love
rosy it is a movie on Netflix with Lily
Collins and Sam Claflin I think it's
like a romantic I don't know about
comedy but it's a romance and it's
something that I would totally watch
anyway so love Rosie is our toast movie
of the day great you could watch it on
Netflix and that's all we got thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe we
also available as a podcast and where
podcasts can be found so that Spotify
iTunes stitcher public radio I already
have cashbox all the places where ever
you listen to podcasts find us the
morning tous and give us a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys so much
we'll see you tomorrow bye